with almost 500 sessions on next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
Cuba at s and V s code 0 2 deployed then
stay tuned because here's the rewind so
what is it like to be a developer in a
Cuban as well
well we've asked developers and the
toller's
is frustrating there's too much
configuration debugging is a pain
application now have so many moving
parts developers simply want to spend
more time in their code at next we've
introduced cloud code a set of
integrated tools that help you remove
the complexity out of Cuba no less and
spend more time on your code today I'm
going to show you
Kludd code for vs code the first feature
that comes with cloud code is visual
cluster Explorer most of the things you
would do with the cube CTL command line
you can do more easily with a graphical
interface you can browse the workloads
least the pods in containers you can
stream the logs or get a terminal inside
a running container with just a few
clicks
one can also create a cluster and
because we want cloud code to be open we
support multiple cloud providers you can
use cloud code on Prem in the cloud or
on your desktop creating a cluster on GK
is so simple with just a few clicks I
start a multi node cluster on Google
Cloud I can even install sto or cloud
run just by ticking a box it's very
useful for developers another feature
that cutcut brings is robust samples to
help you get started no matter the
language you can say bye to the empty
page syndrome' here for example I'm
going to create a go hello world example
each sample comes with source code Dhaka
fires competitors manifest everything is
pre-configured
to easily get started and learn Kludd
code also provides full documentation
for queue various manifest you get two
chips completion value
everything you need to write those
yellow files more easily with cut code
it's also super easy to deploy my code
to criminals cluster I just have to heat
cut code deploy and the IDE will tell me
when it's done
and she give me the URL to connect my
application it's so easy an even more
powerful model is to use cloud cut
continuously deploy it will redeploy my
application automatically each time I
make a change I change the code SAVE and
boom it's deployed this way I can really
just focus on my code and see the
results very quickly now let me show you
how to use cloud code on a more advanced
project
it's a guestbook project that I've just
started it's not fully done yet
I've got a source code and some of the
yamen manifest but not all of them I'm
going to use another profile feature of
code card which is yellow manifest
templates it's super convenient for
beginners once again it helps you avoid
starting from blank page okay I'm going
to finish those yellow files and deploy
my application with cloud code
continuously deploy see the ide tells me
when everything is up and running okay
but my application has a burger so let's
talk about debugging a major pain point
with kubernetes when your application
has a bug you'd like to know what's
going on and it's really not that easy
with given as you have to connect to a
remote container not easy with cloud
code I can use the tools I'm used to and
each debug in vs code and boom debug is
automatically configured to connect to
the container and I can see what's going
on I can add breakpoints I can see
variables I can even fix the bug and the
application is automatically redeployed
it's almost magical to sum up we've seen
how to get started from code samples
we've seen how to create and explore
remote clusters and finally we've seen
how easy it is to deploy and debug our
application so how do you get cloud code
just get it installed from the
marketplace
either on vehicle or IntelliJ it's that
simple
if you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next v1 content thanks
for watching
[Music]